from the star of Pearl Harbor comes the
town not five towns with Johnny Drama
don't mistake that [ __ ]
alright so to a flex credit he's also
the guy who directed Gone Baby Gone and
I really liked Gone Baby Gone Ben
Affleck's directing style kind of has
that Clint Eastwood Mystic River kind of
vibe to it so if no one can forgive
Affleck for reindeer games or daredevil
at least we can say that he produced two
good movies behind camera so the town is
the story of Ben Affleck's character and
his crew who all live in this town
that's famous for breeding bank robbers
yeah like Milwaukee beer Seattle coffee
this place criminals like nobody would
ever visit this place electively in fact
no one would ever willingly visit a
family member there it's just a [ __ ]
shoot but as the story goes there's his
witness from their last robbery who
happens to be pretty hot and Affleck
wants to know if she knows anything
about them so he gets close to her and
you know how the story goes they hook up
however the trailer made it look like
that was the main point of the movie and
that's an aspect of the movie but it's
not actually the main point it's
ultimately about Ben Affleck's
characters life the fact that he's
dating one of the victims of his last
crime who's unwittingly banging the guy
who traumatized her and robbed her bank
and took her captive it's one of the
points of this movie now I thought all
the acting in this movie was really
really good like Ben Affleck who's
really good as the smart knucklehead
robber with a heart Jeremy Renner a nice
name by the way
aka the dude from National Lampoon
senior trip he was good as that really
trigger-happy loose cannon kind of
friend that you know is just gonna cause
problems in the movie and Dylan
McDermott and Harvey Dent's lovechild
was really good as the FBI agent who's
hunting them all so good directing good
acting you top it all off with a good
supporting cast and a good script and I
you have a good movie oh and Blake
Lively's in it and she's just way hot I
mean you can scrounge her up any way you
want try to make her look like any bar
skank in Boston but in the end she's
just still really hot however I respect
her as an actor did she have lines in
this movie so I do not even know which
one of my ratings I would actually give
this movie I don't think it falls under
any one category so I'm gonna give it
the it's like Gone Baby Gone with no
gone babies and more guns and bank
robberies what there's not a rating well
it is today Gone Baby Gone was still my
favorite of the two but the town was
really solid so the town and devil I
liked them both this week weird but if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more than click
here to see more